à événement spécial un dispositif
spécial un compte à rebours géant est
installé ce mardi 31 janvier à l'entrée
de la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
sur l'objectif affiché les jours qui
nous séparent de l'organisation de la
ryder cup au golf national à guyancourt
en septembre 2018
une opération pour promouvoir le
troisième événement sportif le plus
suivi au monde derrière les jo et la
coupe du monde de football
pour ceux qui ne pourraient pas
s'imaginer ses 650 millions de foyers
qui vont regarder cet événement à la
télévision et nous attendons bien sûr
pour cette grande compétition en
septembre 2018
soixante mille visiteurs par jour dont
une grande partie transite seront ici
par la gare de 50 abandonne chaque jour
plus de 70000 personnes passeront devant
ce décompte géant l'horloge virtuel a
déjà attiré l'oeil des passants
je ne suis pas adepte de golf quoi qu'en
fait je connais pas trop bon messi mais
ça là pour découvrir cette discipline
c'est une bonne chose
oui oui ça permet de découvrir parce
qu'il ya des disciplines sportives qu'on
connaît peu il ya beaucoup de passion
qui peuvent le voir c'est ma manche et
patrux existait avant de passer devant
le panneau en fait donc voilà les gens
vont voir le geste du golfeur la pendule
se pose la question puisse les
animations qui sont en cours son
excellente c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on
fasse il faut qu'on sorte plus de notre
golf et venir voir les gens dans les
prochains mois d'autres opérations de
communication sur cette coupe du monde
du golf sont organisées dans les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
avec ce dispositif les yvelinois
n'auront plus d' excuse pour manquer le
train de la ryder cup 2018